こんにちは映画大好きはめ長です24時間
映画館
[音楽]
生活あありがとうございますありがとう
ございます頑張ります今回ですねこちら
立川シネマシティさんにお邪魔しており
ますなんとですねこの24時間映画館生活
のために映画館貸し切っており
ますすごいよこれはもうできない普通本当
にご協力ありがとうございますいやなんか
ね一見なくそうと思うじゃないですか意外
と長時間の映画とか見てるとやっぱ椅子に
座ってて辛くなったりすることもあると
思うのでそれの24
時間ちょっとどどうなんすかなルールと
かってあるんですかざっくりそうすねま
映画館なんでま基本的には席は立たないで
欲しいですね席は立たないえっとそれは
あの上映中にわらずことですかそうですま
トイレとかしょうがない時はオーですはい
はいはいそれはあれですかあの上映中じゃ
なくてもですか上映中じゃなくてもお願い
したいですなるほど確かにもうこれ俺この
動画流れてる間上映中ですから皆さんね
この動画はじゃちょっと足らないようにし
ますこれケツの痛みとの戦いだな確かに
結構きついと思いますねそうだね
エコノミー証群とか足と腰腰とかおがどう
なるかがちょっとかなり不安でありますね
他に何かあるんですかこうルールというか
ま一応映画館なんで映画は見放題ですはい
熱いま映画見れれば乗り切れるみたいな
とこありますそんなずっと見てなければ
いけないとかそういうのはないもんねそう
ですね見たい時に見れると見たい時に見れ
ます勝った気じゃないですか今日こんな
ずっと座ってこうやって映画見てば悪ん
でしょ一応救済措置としてはい今回も
サイコロルー3時間に1回おお
なるほどま3が1回振れるとしたら7回
ぐらいか7回最後振るチャンスがあるよね
でもどうせ救済措置じゃないのもあるん
でしょう
少々ちょっとねまだ未知数ですね映画館
長くいっても大体3時間ぐらいだと思うの
でちょっとそれ以上長くいるとどうなるか
がすごい心配なので早速24時間映画館
生活行っていきたいと思い
ますじゃ速行きますねそ前に映画ガといえ
ばやっぱフードコートとかだと思うんです
よあるじゃんドリックフードコーナーあり
ますねちょっと見てきていいですかえでも
行っちゃダメなんだっけ行かないでき
ましょうピキあれも含めて画かんなのにえ
でもどうせ最高である気がするのよさすが
にフードドリンクコナ行けますみたいなで
早速入っていきたいと思いますここが今回
の会場
[音楽]
です
うおおおしゃれこれが今回の私の映画館
シネマCでございますねほシネマCで
ござい
ますいやすごい見て
このなんかロソっぽい関節賞味てんですか
めっちゃ素敵ねここここがlmnはいはい
この結構スインから透明のここら辺はね
ゆったり見てくですねこれどの席にるかも
結
[音楽]
バナここの席もいいっすねただほら見て
ここ通路になってるじゃんはいはいあの他
のお客さんとか遅れて映画館入ってきた時
に結構妨害入るんでたまに苦しい時があ
こここれエロいねこの席このら辺2人席誰
にも邪魔されずに吸われるこれカップル席
ですね俺いつもね映画館
大体結構前行っちゃうんです
よ前すぎるとさ分かるこのさこうなっちゃ
じゃんスクリーン高すぎてああきついっす
ねそうこれで首が痛くなるからこんなに首
上げすぎない大体俺56列目の真ん中が
めっちゃ好きなんだ
よここら辺だねこういうところこういう
ところほらちょうどいいちょうど良くない
この首もそんな辛くないって
いう個人的には俺ここら辺いつも映画ガだ
と取りますねただ今回は映画見るとかより
長生きするかどうかがポイントなのでどう
すこれ場所取り大事だ
よいや後ろの方がいいんじゃないか
なここら辺とかにしようか
ないや待ってなんか怖くなってきた
ちょっとなんか精神崩壊しそうな
気分なんか静ちゃんメカ館でその防音でさ
はい壁見てみほら
そこ本当だなんかね音が外部から遮断され
てる感じがあって若干精神と時の部があり
ますよし決めた俺ここにするじゃあそこで
はいそれでは映画が24時間生活スタート
まで
スタート
[音楽]
静かやななんかいい24時間生活だな腰の
痛さとかはこの後気になるかもしれない
ですけどなんかもう外部の音が全て遮断さ
れててなんかすごい精神的に落ち着けそう
ですね今は
いやこれ余裕だ
多分寝てるだけで終わる
ぞはい映画館24時間生活始まりまし
た
うん寂しい誰もいない映画館で1人
結構なかなかないですねせっかくこんな
でかいスクリーンがあるのでまずは映画を
見たいと思いますというわけで今映画
始まるまでちょっとと待っております一応
15時半からスタートしたので明日の15
時半まで俺は何もなければここから動き
ませんあ映画の準備ができたということな
のでじゃ見ますねせ皆さんにもお見せし
たいんですけども見とか著作権があります
ので雰囲気でお楽しみ
くださいやばいスマホはまなよ
始め
[音楽]
2時間経過しました中ですお尻が痛くなっ
てきまし
[音楽]
た映画見て終わりましたね腰とかはまだ
全然そんな痛くないんですけどもあ
ちょっとでも動きたい感じはありますね
もう1時間でサイコロなのであと1時間
はぼっとし
ます3時間経過しました
はいこれ
ねちょっと怖いねなんか映画見てる時は気
になんなかったんですけど3時間椅子に座
りっぱなしが結構あこれやばいなって
とりあえずサイコロで何出るかがすごい気
になりますねというわけで3時間経ったの
でサイコロ
タイムさあ今回のサイコロタイム何がある
んですか1から6まず1から1えフード
ドリンクコーナーおお映画館っぽいねフド
ドリンクコーナーに行って好きなもん注文
できるって感じええもうじゃ実質ちょっと
だけ動けるってことからそうすでかいすぐ
にでも行きたいです2はいゲームです
ゲームどういうことこの映画館でなんか
スイッチできるらしいですマジえあの
スクリーンにこれでできますあっつそれも
僕のスイッチでやっていいってことですか
そうです映画館で映画なんで2がいいです
え1と2今んとこめっちゃいいけど3はい
3時間離籍でき
ますここから立っていいと離籍なんです
けど映画館内からは出れませんあなるほど
なるほどま映画館生活ですからねえじゃあ
もう根っこ勝ってるしてもいいってこと
構いません寝袋はありますありがとう
ございます実質睡眠だそれもう4はい1
時間迷惑客が来ます1時間迷惑客が来る
どういう来てからのお楽しみであお楽しみ
なるほど迷惑客かたまにまわいますからね
あの分かる後ろここういうこれほらうわ
地味に押されるやつこうこういうやつね
無理無理普通にも出ちゃうそれ来るんかな
ちょっとやですねはいなし
です1番映画館においてのなしは一番
やばいです多分6
はいが見れ
ます苦手なんですよ僕なんか好きだけど
苦手というかあでもさもうでかいじゃん
スクリーン大音量でしょで1人でしょ死ぬ
マジで他のお客さんいるからホラー映画
見れるみたいなとこあるからなちょっと
すごいな貸し切りならではですねいい
でしょうそれではよろしくお願いします
はいありがとうございますま狙いとしては
見た感じ456がちょっと悪そうだったの
で
123石まだもちいけるかな1とか2かと
か12とかいいかな行きます
さあ
[音楽]
やばい
1でかいでかいでかい時刻ちょうど18時
半もう夕ご飯ですよどれぐらい立ててい
ですかけさまあ30分ぐらいあれば余裕で
変えるじゃないですかあそうねそれぐらい
かなまそうですねじゃあ3時間ぶりに経ち
ます
[音楽]
ねああうわ足やっぱカチカチだわ行き
ましょう行きましょう4にってる場じゃ
ない行き
ましょでこのシをこの映画館だけ貸し切り
なだけであってあの
ドリンクフードコーナーお客さんが
いらっしゃるということで静かに行き
ます行くぞい静かに静かに静か
にこれですよ映画といえ
[音楽]
ば上限とかないって無限ですえっと
ホットドッモデルセット80待っ待待
プレミアムポップコーンのキャラメルの
セットでがペプシコーラでホットドック
単品でチュリトスのシナモンの単品メロン
ソーダで以上で大丈夫ですこれ乗り切れる
レベル買ったよも結構学生さんが多いんだ
ね
ここ
なんかいいねありがとうござい
[音楽]
ます2人で来たやつだねこれ
うん彼女と来たみたいになってるけど全部
1人で食うからましょかちょっと
ストレッチしながら戻りたいね確か
にストレッチしながら戻り
ますかなり変な人い
ます本当になってんの
これいやばいやばいやばいやばい首のスト
首の目がいっちゃってるんよもうじゃ戻り
ます
や
ば戻り
ます言てまだ3時間なので全然行けるんだ
けど洗場に戻り
ます敵がありです
かあれにしましょうよしよしよしま全部
一緒なんだけどね俺気づいたわこれね
絶対足伸ばせた方がいいんです
よここです確かに長さ的に窮屈ソスもんね
えそう結構前の席とぶつかりそうで
苦しかったんで
ちょっと最善でいきますはいというわけで
7時前30分以内に戻ってこれましたま
いいタイミングで多分夜ご飯は食べれてる
ような気がしますいただき
[音楽]
ますシネマティックフォト
感で食べるこのポップコーンとドリンクの
味分かるマジでうまいちょ違うのよ
やっぱり俺キャラメルポップコーン1択
ですうめえどで時間あるので映画もう1本
見たいと思いますお願いしますちょ
たくさん買ったんですけどここで全部
食べるのはもったいない次いつ位置出るか
わかんないからちょっと食べ物の飲み物
結構セーブしながらゆっくり時間かけて
食べていきたいと思います大事な食料なの
で
前の席あるやつっておるんだってこうだよ
1番高いとこ見る時相当混んでてもうそこ
しかないってなったらしょうがなくそれ
ですけど喉通ら機に
[音楽]
食べ物バがパパプってかる
はい映画2本目見終わりましたあるあるあ
るっていうなんかインド映画だったんです
けどインドの映画見たことなかったけど
めちゃくちゃ面白かったです普通に感動し
てあっというね時間が過ぎましたねもう
340分でサイコロタイムです寝
[音楽]
ます6時間経過しました最後のタイ
お願いし
ますあの結構疲れてきましたね疲れてきた
と言いますか6時間椅子に座ってることで
多分ね海外行くことぐらいしかないと思う
んですよここは一発ちょっといいの当て
たいですね立ちたい立ちたいというか
ちょっと腰動かしたいけどなんか映画の力
でなんとか行けてる感じはします456
以外でいい
来い
[音楽]
頼む
4迷惑客が1時間来るどういうことだこれ
え貸し切りじゃないの俺の今日ま貸し切り
なんですけどちょ迷惑そうな迷惑だなって
思う人用意してるんでマジダメだよ映画館
は静かに見ないとせっかくの貸し切りなの
に
だよ
それあぶねえ間に合ったあぶねえマジ
でわうわここここにするか
ああっか早く始ねか
な早く始
マジすいませんちょあの足足がちょっと
当ったあはい大丈夫ですはい大丈夫楽しみ
すねあそうそうですねマジで楽しみしてき
たんよそうですよ
ね
う誰だ
[音楽]
よ
もしもし何してんのえ今から映画見んだ
けどマジすいませんすいませんすはいなん
であかかってきちゃったんですいません
ちょっと後でかけますねごめんごめん今今
から映画見るからマジごめんちょっとま
注意されちゃった
から切りました切りましあちょちょマジで
怒れたから本当に本当怒前に切り
ましちょ後でかけるねバイ
バイおせえ
な始始まれよていうか前の人でけえなでか
すぎだろ何にも見えねえじゃ
やくさダオに席移動する
か見えなすいませんちょっと隣ですかあ
全然はいちょ見えなかっあ通知も着といた
方がいいあそうそうちょっとおかして
もらっていいすか全然すませんはい全然
大丈夫ですよスマホがね
なっちゃうもんで電源切った方がいいかも
しれないです電源すか
はい分かりましたちょっとマナモドにし
ときます申し訳ないすいえいえ
全然これなこれ
うざ
うん
何しとんねんお前ごんすか何しとんねん
いや今日迷惑客でかこの方はいつまで
いらっしゃるのこれあと45分
は1時間ぐらいいるのねそうですね
なるほどねよろしくお願いしますあの映画
中だけマジで静にしてくれ確かにそうす
ね本にもう1本ぐらい見ます
[拍手]
かう
始まるやばいすいませんうるさい
[音楽]
ちょっとすご
せ
すごすごくないですかいやそうそうすね
そろそろ帰りますかあ帰りますそうはい
これ残ったんで食べてくださいあいいんす
かマジで食べてくださいあわかりました
ありがとうございますこれもそれもいいか
あじゃちょっと最後だけいいですか
ふざけんありがとうございますありがとう
ございますちょっとコもらってあ
うん
ありがとうございましあありがとうござい
ましたお気をつけてうんうんふんうんふん
うんありがとうございましたお気をつけ
てお気をつけてありがとうござい
ますうなんかコーラ
があザリガニの腐った匂いに変わってる
はいというわけで8時間経過しましたえ
迷惑のお客さも帰って結構静かになりまし
たね映画見てると時間はあっという間に
過ぎるんですけども確実に体力が減ってて
ますお尻が痛い腰と首と24時間後僕は
まともに歩けるのでしょうか心配です
とりあえずもう1時間頑張ればサイコロ
タイムなので頑張り
ます9時間経過しまし
た
あのいや全然その映画は楽しいんですよ
映画は楽しいんですけどもちょっとあの首
がかなりこの地で苦しい
えもういいかなって9時間ぐらいで
ちょっともう見れますけどもこの先も見れ
ますけどもちょっとなんか別のことしたい
なみたいな感じはあります正直このサコで
奇跡を起こすしかないでしょもう日付も
変わっちゃって深夜ですよではサイコロ
タイムもう映画はあのやや映画館で絶対
言っちゃいかんけど映画ややもう4本見
てるよすごい
よ456
[音楽]
いこれ
は2ですかねこれ
は2ですよしよしよしよしよしよししょ2
って何でしたっけゲームですゲームどう
いうことゲームてちょっと準備するんで
はい待ってください分かりましたじゃはめ
さん
はいどうぞプロコンじゃないです
か
ええかかんでスイッチ
やすごくない
これあすごい見て初め映画館
で
うわこれ頑張れるわでこっからはい3時間
はゲーム紹題ですえ映画館でいいすか3
時間だけですでけえ映画館でスマブラでき
るってことできますすっごでも画面でか
すぎてこれ結構やばい
な見
ていやすごや
ばやばいオーケストラや
[音楽]
すげえじゃお願いします音すごいっすね
マジえやばい音
やばいすごいすごいマジすかお願いします
ラグなくないあまりいやマジ
ない待ってやって見えするこれはいはい
はいはい
くやばい
まずいよある
よよしよし
よしまずい
よあこれなっ
たえあれで一気にやってた
わすごいなんかもうよくわかんないも何を
見てるのか
あの首
やばい
入入る
入割れちゃった
よ
めまずいまずい
まずいここでここでいで1でも暮らせるん
だやめて
くれ
[音楽]
よいしょいつもと感覚が違いすぎ
て
[音楽]
まずいよまずいありますありますあり
ますうわ
やばい発
[音楽]
発べ
おし違う
もうやばい多分疲労が
やばいもこ位置がんすぎてみます1回は
ありです1回はセーフにしましょう変え
ましょう1分以内で分かりまし
たここ
でここでやりたいねいやこれはこれなら
多分いけるやべえ
[音楽]
ややばいもう無
さこの位置で後ろに行けば行くほど強い説
あるだっ視野やばいもん今もう全部見える
[音楽]
ここ
はい10時間経過しましたゲームできてる
んでなんかメンタル的には助かるんです
けどなんて言えばいいんでしょう目が痛い
です映像大画面で見すぎて目がめっちゃ
痛くなってきましたちょっと視力が心配
です
ね楽しいからいっ
[音楽]
か
ああはい12時間経過しまし
た若干座り続けることへの限界を感じまし
たこれは多分ね小学生の多動症だった頃の
俺は無理です動きたいもうとりあえず動き
たさがやばいあと画面ずっと見てるんです
よ今もずっとポケモンやってたんですけど
結局あの映画見てるのとな変わらなく
ずっと映像見てたので目がかなり疲れまし
たねちょっと次映画見れるかわかんないな
これ体も痛いしギリギリのラインで残り
半分を向かいました深夜3時半です
サイクロタイムこれマジで大事ですよここ
本当にゲーム個人的には楽しかったけどね
結局あのほぼなしと等しい行きますこれ
マジで結構運命変えるダロ量
[音楽]
来い2って何だっけゲーム
ああもうちょい頑張りますねおかしくなっ
ちゃう
[音楽]
やばいすごいしてるただいま5時半
です14時間経過しましたさすがすにね
ちょっと疲れてきましたね15時間もこの
椅子座ってるんですよいや2回ゲームあっ
てて正解でしたね楽しいでなんとか映画館
に入れてる感じはあり
ますあと1時間でサイコロ頑張り
[音楽]
ます15時間経過しました朝の6時半です
俺はこの椅子で寝れる日が来るのでしょう
か椅もせずひたすらにゲームをやっており
ましたゲームやってるのも結局やってる
ことはスクリーン見てるので映画見てるの
と一緒ではありますがゲームの方がその脳
みそは考えて楽しんでるから体は限界頭は
まだいけるみたいな感じ
ですあと眠いですこの椅子で座りこいんだ
けどネレアしないんだよなちょっとなんと
かこのサイコロタイム
で世界を変えたい行きます行きます
はい
これは3で3
時間離席できますありがとうございました
ケツ行っ
たやばいケツ2つになってる俺いやもも
もも腰痛い
やばいあと今一番何がしたいかって言うと
画面見ないようにしたいスクリーン結構ね
目がすごい疲れましたのでちょっと離席
するかとりあえず移動できるってことよね
はいこれあれです
か寝てもいいんですか
どうぞもう6時半だよ朝のバチ徹夜し
ちゃったけどはいというわけで寝ますね
寝袋もありますのでよしちょマジでマジで
寝ますも
よいしょ
いやあせまここで寝るやつあんまいなく
ないいやあんまいないっすなかなか
経験をしてる気がしますが私はこれを抜か
せていただきますおやすみ
なさい
うわあ快適
[音楽]
だ
欲し
て床がガチガチすぎてソファーより硬
です腰
[音楽]
がもうすぐ18時間経過しようとしており
ます席から立てたの良かったんです
けど
床腰折れました映画館のこの席と席の間の
通路で寝る人生待ってたとは思いません
でしたちょっとまたこっからいついつから
立てるかわかんないのでちょっと動いて
おきますマジ動けることに感謝てすごいよ
ねやばい終わっちゃう終わっちゃう終わっ
ちゃう終わっちゃうやだやだ
はい18時間経過しましたサイコロタイム
行き
ます
[音楽]
3死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ
この精神状態で
これほら映画ですね寝てない
このこのせホラが
人じゃなくなるけど
いい救急者の準備だけきたんだはい席は
どうしますか結構大事です席大事だねこれ
これまた席リセてきてますもんねはいどう
しよっかないやほら怖いんでさすがにもう
一番奥でみ
[音楽]
ます
ああ
[音楽]
ああ怖かった
一斉もできんかった20時間経過しまし
たも何本映画を見たことでしょうかゲーム
やってる時間忘ると多分
10時間9時間ぐらいずっと映画の
スクリーンを見てい
ます映画好きからするとたまらない
でしょうねもうなんか動くことを諦め始め
てきましたお尻と腰が痛いですあと
頑張り
ます21時間経過しまし
たはさん大丈夫です大丈夫じゃない
です
はい待って何時間見てるマジで
多分
10時間ぐらい見てるよね見てますね
なんかこの真っ黒な空に1日いることも
ないからなんか体内時計がバグってそうだ
し腰が本当に激痛ですねこれでどんな国に
行く飛行機にも乗れそう
ですただしファーストクラスに限るやり
ましょうかサイコロタイムです最後の
サイコロタイムですマジで決めていいもう
行きます
ほ
[音楽]
さあ待て待て待て待て待て待て待て待待て
待て待て待て待て6
です単じけすさんちょっともう最善マジ
無理っす本当に首的にもってことですか首
もだいぶもうこれが普通だもん
俺えどうする咳がありですかまあ最後なん
でやっぱ1番いいところで見てほしいです
ねありがとうさすがに最後はね気持ちよく
この企画終わりたいから俺座席移動します
ねすぐすぐきますさすがに最後はうわ腰
いっ
たさすがにもうねほらこの無理だから
ちょっと行こうなんか目がやばいもう本当
にま最後はちょっとさすがにいいところで
見たいのでこの最高列1番後ろから見たい
と思い
[音楽]
ますだもう無理本当に無理だも間違えた
間違えたこいご早い間違え早い
[音楽]
よ
ああさああと1時間になりました23時間
経過しました
なんか突然時計が壊れたりしてちょっと
怖いんですけどさすがに残り3時間でずる
はしませんあと1時間頑張ります
[音楽]
あはいというわけでホラが1本見回りまし
たなんか時計が突で狂っちゃって電池
入れ替えてもつかなくなって普通にあの
心霊現3半まであと30目と精神的に限界
が来てます頑張り
[音楽]
ますお疲れ様
です疲労感の顔がすごいな
始め
さん終わりましたか終わりまし
た高かったこれ外出ていいんですか
はいぶに24時間達成しまし
た
[音楽]
あありがとうございまし
たやばい24時間ぶりにこの扉出るんだ
けどこ外の世界ってことでしょうはい
[音楽]
ああこれが現世かお疲れ様でしたお疲れ様
でし
[音楽]
た
ねむ24時間ぶりの外
だ曇りはい24時間お疲れ様でし
た映画7本ぐらいえ24時間で見ることが
できましたなんか今までの24時間生活と
違ってそのなんかきつと
かきついっすわ座ってるだけで楽でしょう
と思うじゃないですか飛行機とか新幹線
長い時間座っててみてくださいもう本当に
結構暴れたくなっちゃうその何何暗いじゃ
ないですか映画館真っ暗の閉鎖空間なで
すごいなんかメンタル的になんか暴れたい
衝動に狩られる瞬間とかありましたけども
なんとかね素敵な映像そしてゲームに助け
られて乗り切ることができましたあ全然
ご飯食べてないの気づいた確かに最初しか
食べてないですえそう夜食べてそれから1
回も食べてないから結構ねもう20時間
近く何も食べてない気がしますはい映画の
力ってすごいですね座ってるだけの何も
ない真っ黒な空間でも映像が楽しければ
なんとか乗り切れることが今回分かりまし
た
え映画館は3ヶ月行かないでおこうと思い
ますありがとうございまし
[音楽]
た